homeless and in desperate need of help
36 villages in eastern sudan have been
inundated by water
and the threat from floods isn't over
yet
the torrential rains began more than
five weeks ago el gash a seasonal river
near the city of casella has reached
unprecedented levels and threatens to
spill into surrounding areas
flooding is our biggest problem we've
been asking for a bridge to be built in
this area since 2017
but authorities never responded to our
demands
local authorities say several people
have lost their lives in this area so
far fifteen thousand homes have been
completely or partly damaged
slaves of agricultural land have been
destroyed thousands of families have
lost their livelihoods
it continues to rain and people have
lost their homes now they need shelters
mosquito nets insecticides
castle authorities are appealing for
humanitarian help
the people who have been affected were
already among the poorest in this area
so we would like to ask good hearted
people and organizations to intervene
and bring more help
several countries including qatar and
saudi arabia have already responded
large shipments of aid have been sent by
air and are being distributed but
logistics issues are delaying the
operation many of the affected areas are
remote and have been impossible to reach
because the roads have been cut off by
floods
14 states across sudan need immediate
help
the deadly floods have caused extensive
damage to property especially in the
states of cordovan darfur al jazeera and
white nile
with a few more weeks of the wet season
remaining
fears are mounting but the situation for
those already affected might go from bad
to worse muhammad al-jazeera cartoon